So moving on from those kind of fundamental components
onto something a little bit more content-focused,
let's take a look at animation.
Animation is made up of a kind of a set of different assets
to piece the whole system together in Unreal.
We have skeleton assets, skeletal meshes, physics
assets, animation sequences, anim montages, animation
instance, or otherwise referred
to as animation blueprint.
And lastly, anim notifies, which actually
isn't represented by an asset in the content browser,
but is still a pretty important concept
to get your head around.
So we'll start off with skeleton assets.
The term skeleton is probably something
that most of us are used to when we're
talking about animations within the context of video games.
It's a hierarchical framework of bones
that are linked together and can be
used to define complex motions.
In Unreal, these are associated with the animation data.
So a skeleton asset has the bones in it, the bone data,
but also is associated tightly with the animations that
are for that skeleton.
The skeleton asset can be shared by several skeletal meshes,
and we don't always require exact matches,
meaning we can have meshes that are missing certain bones
and the animations still function.
So the elements that the asset is
kind of responsible for animation retargeting,
which we already touched a little bit on, the idea
that characters that have the same skeleton,
but might have slightly different portions and things
like that, that can be done utilizing the skeleton asset.
The skeleton asset also stores sockets.
Sockets are a really important gameplay concept
where you might not necessarily have a bone in the middle
of your character's hand, but you often
want to be able to attach items there,
such as guns or pickups they're holding or torches
and that kind of thing.
And so sockets is a kind of additional layer
that lets us add game accessible,
something like bones onto our skeleton.
And those are stored in the skeleton asset.
They also store animation notifies,
which are ways for animations to communicate to gameplay code
to fire off certain events.
We have animation curves.
Animation curve data is like an additional set of curves
that we can use to drive certain properties,
for example, material blends or things like morph targets.
And lastly, we have animation slot names.
So slot names are used on an animated character
to define kind of channels for animation montages to play in.
This is really important when you want certain montages
to only be in play at certain times
and maybe to only affect certain parts of the character.
Slot names become very, very powerful there.
So the skeletal mesh actually represents
the kind of visual mesh for our animated character.
So it's actually the surface data.
And we've highlighted both SKM Mani and SKM Quinn here.
SKM being the kind of standard nomenclature
for the kind of prefix before a skeletal mesh,
hence the name asset.
And those vertices are essentially tied to our bones.
But the point being that both of these characters
would share the same skeleton.
And this is what we're talking about,
the idea that by doing that,
by having these skeletal meshes
both share the same skeleton,
it means we can recycle animations
and we can reuse the same animations
on different looking characters.
The skeletal mesh itself actually holds a reference
to the skeleton that it is driven by.
And skeletal meshes are also responsible
for the kind of lodding of the visuals.
So lodding is probably a term we're all familiar with,
level of detail.
As you get further away from this asset,
obviously it's going to kind of reduce infidelity
because we don't need 4K textures
when something's a mile away.
So it's actually the skeletal mesh
that is handling that lodding.
It's important to highlight as well
that because even though we might play animations
on our skeletal mesh,
that's actually what animations are suitable
for a skeletal mesh,
because animations are actually driven
by the skeleton and are driving the skeleton.
What animations are suitable for the skeletal mesh
is actually defined by a skeleton asset.
Then we have the physics asset.
This is essentially a simplified representation
of our skeletal mesh.
And this is kind of an unreal concept.
It's not a kind of broad thing
that you would see necessarily
in other pieces of software,
but it's how we represent
very often the collision of a skeletal mesh.
So I'll very, very quickly demonstrate this.
If we get our project open,
we've actually got,
if we jump to this, we can see,
if we jump inside our physics asset,
you can see we have these kind of like a set of balls
or kind of like various shapes.
It's quite often capsules and spheres or cubes.
And you can see we have a representation
of our kind of character skeleton here on the left.
And under each skeleton, under each bone,
we can see the elements
that are actually like tied to these bones
and what bones are attached to those bones
and what primitives are attached to each of these
to represent that mesh.
So if you look here over here in the details panel,
we can see in this body setup,
we've got a list of primitives.
And on the clavicle,
we have one capsule that represents,
the kind of, that we're kind of vaguely using
to map in a very, very simplified way
what our kind of skeletal mesh looks like.
And again, I keep using the term skeletal mesh here
rather than the actual skeleton
because it's the skeletal mesh
that our physics asset is tied to.
That's because even two characters
that have the same skeleton,
they might have very, very different proportions.
They might have very, very different geometry.
So it's the skeletal mesh
that the physics asset is actually trying
to give us a simplified representation of.
The kind of obvious example when we would need this
is anything kind of collision related.
So that might be line traces, overlaps,
actual collision itself,
physics simulation, cloth simulation,
anything like that where the actual skeletal mesh
might have way too many vertices
to check against to be efficient.
We can use this for a kind of simplified version
of that collision.
Yes, the reference skeleton
is paired with the actual skeletal mesh.
And the last thing to mention
is that when you have a blueprint
that is using any skeletal mesh,
you can actually override the physics asset
that is used by that blueprint.
So even though the physics asset
is tied to the skeletal mesh,
at the component level,
at the skeletal mesh component,
you can actually override the physics asset
that it's using at runtime.
Animation sequences are essentially
what the actual asset in Unreal
that represents an animation.
They're the kind of building block that we use
to play animations either through the Animation Blueprint
or on their own.
You can play,
without the concept of an Animation Blueprint,
you can actually just play an animation on its own.
It's less common
because it's much, much more restrictive.
The vast majority of the time we're doing,
certainly for character animation,
we need a little bit more complexity out of it.
But in the context that we just kind of need
a single fire and forget animation,
you can have just a single animations playing.
So animations are made up of key frames.
This is probably concepts
that most people are relatively familiar with.
It's not an Unreal specific thing.
But the idea being that you have
an animation might last six seconds.
And along that time,
you would key frame bones
to be in different positions and rotations,
and then the vertices that those bones are tied to
are gonna drive the mesh
that that skeleton is tied to.
As we said before,
animations are tied to specific skeleton assets,
not the skeletal mesh itself.
And animation sequences can be played through code,
but more typically,
they're utilized through the animation blueprint.
Again, we touched on it a little bit
in the skeleton asset,
but whilst the skeleton asset stores the curves,
they would obviously be used and driven
in the actual animation.
So it's our animation sequences
that would drive that curve data
that we might use for things like material parameters
or morph targets.
We can actually also use root motion in animation.
So root motion for the term
for people who aren't familiar with that
is the idea that we can affect the position of our root
of our entities actual position with our animation.
So we read what changes the animation have made
to the root of that skeleton.
And we interpret that as actual movement of the character.
So you can do that through animation sequences,
but in the context that your game
is networked multiplayer,
doing it through an animation sequence
isn't gonna be suitable.
You would need to move to animation montages,
which brings us conveniently onto animation montages.
Animation montages are the kind of step up
in complexity from animation sequences.
They give us a way to play animation
directly through blueprints or in C++.
So whereas with a standard animation sequence,
we can assign an animation to a skeleton for that to play,
it's more typical that when we're trying
to play animations at runtime,
even if that's possibly simultaneous
to something that already has an animation instance
controlling it,
we can do that through animation montages.
And animation montages through the use of slots
are actually kind of intended often to be used
in conjunction with an animation instance
that might be controlling it 95% of the time,
but you're playing animation montage in certain contexts
for certain gameplay scenarios.
So what animation montages do,
they do function very much like an animation,
but they give us the ability
to stitch several animations together.
So if we take an example, a jump animation,
which we've got here,
you can see this montage is actually made up
of several sections.
We have a default section,
which is essentially a jump start.
We have a loop and then we have a land.
And land plays quite no noxiously loud sound,
but essentially this is actually made up of three animations.
We can see we've got the jump animation,
we've got the falling loop,
and we've got the land animation.
But as it's kind of already been demonstrated,
these sections can feed into one another.
So by default, when you're jumping,
we don't know how long we're necessarily going to play
the loop animation for.
So what the loop animation do unsurprisingly is loop.
And we can define that in the montage itself.
This isn't default behavior.
We've specified here that we want the for loop
to play itself repeatedly.
And what we can do is then jump between these sections.
So these names actually matter.
With gameplay, we can essentially drive this
and say, jump to the loop section,
jump to the land section.
So when our character lands,
we would obviously jump out of the loop section
into our land section to finish the animation off.
So the animation instance is the last
of these animation based assets.
And it's also probably the most complicated.
For a start, there's a naming convention.
Animation instance is the term used in C++,
content level.
It's referred to as the animation blueprint,
hence the prefix ABP.
And it's essentially the point at which
we stitch everything together
when we need something more complicated.
They're very typically used for player animations,
anything where we would need
several different animations.
We need branching logic.
We need many different things coming in
and we maybe need different kind of layers
affecting different parts of the body.
Anything that's kind of more complex
than fire and forget animations
or single loops that we're performing
would probably require an animation blueprint.
These are broken up into kind of two key components.
We have the event graph and the anim graph.
And we'll go into both of those
in more detail in just a second.
But just before we do that,
we're gonna move on to anim notifies
to cover that just a little bit
and then we'll loop back.
No pun intended.
So anim notifies, as mentioned earlier,
are ways that we can essentially trigger
certain gameplay behaviors from an animation.
It's pretty obvious why that might be useful,
but very often we have certain gameplay side events
that we need to happen in sync with animation.
For example, if our character is swinging a sword,
they might need to grunt,
play a sound at the right time.
Very often games have important things
like collision or attacks synced up
with the animations for those things
so that it's very clear to the player
when these things do and don't happen.
So we might have a certain point in that sword swing.
We activate the collision for our swords,
for our actual weapon so that it can deal damage.
And then towards the end of the swing
is when we disable it again.
And all of that should be driven by the animation itself
rather than us having to really intricately sync up
the code with the animation
and just hope that the two things line up.
There are two ways
that we can actually create these anim notifies.
I was slightly misleading before
when I said anim notifies aren't represented by an asset
because you can make a blueprint
that inherits from the anim notify class,
which is what we'll look at first.
And the second way of doing it
is implementing custom notifies in your animations
for your skeleton,
which are then implemented
on a kind of animation instance
by animation instance basis
for kind of more bespoke behavior.
So let's actually kind of just look into that a little bit
and then we'll kind of demonstrate
how we might actually implement them.
So first off with making anim notifies
that inherit from the anim notify class,
so the actual blueprints
that you'd see in your content browser,
we've got two types that we can author.
We have anim notifies, just the plain one,
and that's just a kind of single event
that will occur in whatever point
you specify in your animation.
And then we have anim notify state.
These function relatively similarly,
but anim notify state is an anim notify
that might have some kind of duration.
So we have a begin, an end,
and for every animation tick,
and it's important to highlight animation tick,
so it's not necessarily always in sync
with your game's world tick,
depends on your animations frame rate and things like that,
then you would have received this notify tick.
So anim notify just has a receive notify function
that you can override.
Anim notify state has notify begin,
notify end, notify tick.
Both of these events also have a function
that you can override called get notify name.
And this is essentially a way
to provide a friendly name to the editor
so that when you put these notifies
in your animation sequence timeline,
you can kind of see just without even having
to go into the detail what kind of notify it is.
Just a couple of things to mention about these functions.
These are const, so that really massively affects
the way you need to be thinking
about what you can do in an anim notify.
You can't edit state of the notify itself.
You can't store variables that you use for later,
which is obviously particularly relevant
for anim notify state where you might instantly think,
oh, I will fire off some events
that will tick frequently,
like a kind of damage timer,
or I'll have some kind of countdown or something like that.
Unfortunately, that's not completely suitable
within the anim notify itself
because these functions are const.
But as you can see, quite a lot of information
is provided through the function.
So we have the mesh component
that the anim notify is actually being run on.
You have the animation that is being fired,
and then you just have some additional data
about the actual event itself.
And for the anim notify state,
we also get an additional couple of variables.
We have the duration.
So when our notify begin,
we have the total duration this event is going to take.
And on our tick, we have the kind of tick duration again
of the since the last animation frame.
Just to kind of quickly actually demonstrate
these being used rather than just talking in abstracts,
let's jump into the project
and take a quick look at some ways
in which we've actually implemented these.
So if we go to our content browser and we find notifies,
these are just two example notifies that I've made.
So these aren't built into Unreal.
These are managed custom ones that we've made.
And this is an example of just our plain notify.
This is quite a typical thing that you might see.
And this is a notify to represent a footfall.
And because obviously we can't fully author
just playing a sound in a walking animations or whatever,
because it depends on what kind of surface
you're standing on.
What we do instead is we,
this notify has like a ball built into it.
And you can actually demonstrate
actually using this unnotifying animation
to kind of show how that's made available to us,
but we can choose which foot it is.
And then based on which foot it is,
we get a socket from our skeleton,
which we talked about before.
We trace downwards to the floor on the visibility channel.
And if we hit something,
then we check what kind of physical surface it is.
And then we play a different sound
based on what kind of surface.
So that just lets us do like a ray chase,
check against the physics type of the floor.
And then that way, if we're walking on concrete,
we can play a concrete footstep sound effect.
If we're walking on dirt,
we can play a dirt foot for sound effect.
An example of the animation and notify state
might just be a spin attack or something.
I couldn't immediately think
of such a fantastic implementation here,
but yeah, essentially what I'm doing
is just on our notify tick,
I'm doing a sphere overlap with every object around us,
other than the owner of our mesh component,
so essentially ourselves.
And based on this damage radius that we can specify,
we're applying damage to every actor
with a damage per second value that we can specify.
Because it's const, we're not changing this value,
we can specify that in the notify itself,
and then just multiply that by our frame delta time.
So that would be an example of like a character doing
a sphere attack or something like that.
So if we actually try and utilize these
and can just quickly go through the process
of implementing one,
if we just went to our jump animation, for example,
maybe I want to do our foot trace
just as I come off the floor to kind of make it different.
We do a different jump sound effect
depending on what kind of floor we're on.
So the way you add a notify
is you have this notify tracks here.
It's not actually in the notify here
because you can have multiple notify tracks.
So this one is saying this is the first notify track.
So you simply right click here and you go to add notify.
Now we've got add notify,
which is our kind of play notify.
We had add notify state,
which is our kind of duration based one.
So if I were to do our play notify,
you can see we've got a couple of different options here.
We'll come back to this in a second,
but the ones up the top here are our custom notify.
So these are the ones we can kind of manually
add ourselves.
They aren't tied to an inherited class
in our content browser.
These are kind of just baked into this skeleton.
But the ones that we've specified by a class here,
the options here,
we can see that Unreal has already got some pre-built ones.
So we've got the kind of standard place particles effect,
play sound, but here's the one that we made ourselves
is BP anim foot trace.
So if we select that,
we can see this is the friendly name
that we specified through our function.
So if I just go here,
we can see I've called that foot trace
and that's why the word foot trace is coming up here.
And if I select that,
we can actually see a couple of details
actually about the notify itself.
So we can specify its color.
We can specify the type and just some additional stuff
about whether it's got a chance to trigger
and all these kinds of things.
Oh, and last of all is we can see we have this,
we made this variable public.
And so we made this B right foot public.
If I'd given it a category,
it would be in a different category here,
but as it is, it's fallen under default
and we can see we've got the right foot.
So we can specify which of the two feet
we should be tracing from.
So in this case, it would be our left,
but if we're doing a run animation or a walk animation
where it's gonna be alternating,
obviously we can have multiple instances
of this on notify
and then we could be tracing from a different foot
based on, we can change that property.
Just for an example,
if I were to then use my notify state,
we can see if I had to do my spin attack,
you can see this now has two key frames
and this is kind of our duration.
So we can see it would be firing every animation frame
for this duration.
Here we would have our begin called,
here we would have our end called,
pretty self-explanatory.
The last thing that we can do,
which we'll come back to later,
but just whilst we're already here,
is actually make custom notifies.
So any existing custom notifies we have,
we can just add here.
We all, we can type in,
or we can just manage our notifies and add a new one.
So if I were just to add a custom notify,
I can just do new notify here and just call it Bob.
And this we'll come back to later,
but if I wanted to do a custom notify,
which isn't gonna have a blueprint class tied to it,
I can just do that here.
And I've now got Bob as an option,
but this would need to be implemented on the anim instance,
which we'll get to in a second.
So that's the kind of two class-based implementations.
But the last thing that bears mentioning
is if I jump back to the presentation,
you'll notice both of these functions,
or well, really all of these functions return a bool.
You may be wondering what that bool is actually used for.
If you go into Unreal's C++ code implementation
of these function calls,
you'll see that this bool actually isn't used.
So it's likely it's some kind of legacy use
that's from previous versions of the engine,
but it doesn't actually mean anything.
So just kind of bear that in mind
is you don't need to worry too much about that.
To implement the other kind of anim notify,
we're gonna have to talk a little bit more
about the animation instance.
So let's actually return to that.
As we said before,
the animation instance is broken into two key graphs,
the event graph and the anim graph.
The event graph is more in common
with things you would have seen in things like Blueprints,
other graphs you've seen in Unreal Editor.
It's essentially responsible for reacting
to gameplay events, getting notifies from things,
updating the animation Blueprints idea
of information that's going on
outside of the animation itself.
So this is really what gathers up the information.
And then that information is used by the anim graph
to drive the final pose.
It's the anim graph that actually drives the visuals
of that frame for how a character
or whatever it is we're animating is gonna be posed
and what shape its skeleton is going to be in.
So when you're going to create a new animation instance
or an anim blueprint,
there's a couple of events that would be,
first ones you would be commonly using.
These would actually be in by default,
but the reference we're using here is ABPMani
from the third person template.
So this isn't code that I've written.
This is preexisting code.
And we have Blueprint Initialize Animation.
This is the equivalent of begin play from your Blueprint.
So it's a kind of fired once right at the beginning.
And it's where you would do initial setup
for things like, as you can see here,
we're caching this character reference
just so we don't have to recast
every time we want access to it.
That would be a typical use.
And then we also have the Blueprint Update Animation,
which is a little bit more like our tick.
So called every animation frame
for any kind of real-time data
that we need to update on the fly.
So both of these have a C++ underlying them
as with all of Unreal.
So let's actually just take a quick look at that.
If I open up the C++, we have the anim instance here.
And if we go to line, I think it's 315.
I have it off the top of my head.
Yes.
So here we have the kind of event
that drives our kind of begin played like game called,
our Blueprint Initialize Animation.
It's actually called inside
the Initialize Animation function in C++.
And you can see we kind of do a little bit of setup here.
We make sure that we've got a skeletal mesh component.
We make sure that we've got a valid anim blueprint class
for that skeleton.
We calculate some bone things,
and then we call these two events.
We have the native initialize animation
and the blueprint initialize animation.
So this isn't a blueprint native event.
It does call the C++ path first,
and then it goes on to call the blueprint path.
Similarly, we have something kind of similar setup
for our tick.
And if I just look at my notes,
the line for that is 634.
So we kind of have a very, very similar setup here.
This is inside the update animation.
This is the kind of like C++ level tick.
And we do a little bit of something a little bit similar.
We do some checking, checking that data is valid,
checking that we've got a skeletal mesh component,
updating our bones and things like this.
And then we come to our kind of two key events.
The kind of one thing that we wanted to highlight here
is it's that same structure here
where we have this native update animation.
So if you're going to make a C++ class
that inherits from your anim instance for any reason,
you can always trust that it's our native C++ version
of the function that gets called.
And after that, we have our blueprint update animation.
Something that's worth highlighting here,
these are the kind of two most common events
for us to be using.
But if both of these will fire
before the anim graph derives its pose.
So like we said,
it's kind of there to gather the data
for the anim graph to use.
So it makes sense that these are fired first.
But if you need some logic that fires
after you're certain the anim graph
is decided on its final pose for that frame,
there is a separate event called blueprint post evaluate
that you can use if you need some logic to fire
after the skeleton has defined its pose for that frame.
Also here is, like we said,
where we would be defining the implementations
of our custom anim notifiers.
So if we were to kind of like right click
on inside the event graph of an animation blueprint
and that the skeleton of that animation blueprint is using
has custom notifies built into it,
when you right click,
you would see a list of add anim notify events like this.
This isn't gonna show up
for all our blueprint based anim notifiers
because the understanding is
they already have an implementation.
So this is only for the custom notifiers.
If we actually jump to our ABP Manny,
for the most part,
what I've been demonstrating is the kind of default,
but I have actually added
just a little bit of our own logic.
So this is a notify that I've added,
but just to kind of demonstrate that,
if we go to our add anim notify event,
you can see we've got a list here of all our custom ones.
We've even got that Bob that we just added ourselves,
just in the kind of section before,
and we have footplant left, footplant right.
All of these, these are actually custom anim notifiers
that come on Manny by default,
and Bob is obviously that one we just added.
So as a kind of example,
all I did here was implement what happens on footplant left.
This naming convention isn't required of AN,
but, you know, AN standing for anim notify, quite obviously.
And what we're doing is a little bit like our foot trace,
but I was just trying to demonstrate
something slightly different.
So on our footplant left,
we're checking for the left socket on our skeleton
and we're tracing downwards.
So like our foot trace for the playing the sound effect,
but what I've done instead is I've added a surface type
to our physics settings of ice.
And what I'm doing is I'm checking
if that surface type is ice,
then I'm rolling a random dice.
And if that value is less than our slip chance,
so if it's, you know, meets our slip chance,
then I'm setting this slipping ball to true.
And the idea being that if you're walking on ice,
every time your foot lands on the floor,
there's a chance you're gonna slip over
cause you don't want to slip whilst if you're running,
you don't want to slip whilst both your feet in the air
cause that's gonna look a little bit silly.
You slip as your footing is hitting the ice.
And then we can use that
to drive some kind of custom animations in our anim graph.
So if you already mentioned,
whereas the event graph is where we react
to gameplay logic, we listen for events,
we update our information.
The anim graph is where we actually construct
our final pose that our mesh is in.
The reference we've got here in this image,
and just I'll actually jump into the engine
and show this, is again,
our modified version of the Mani ABP.
So all of this content here is what you would see
if you opened that up,
apart from this additional blend poses by Bool,
which we've added in based on our slipping logic
that we just talked about before.
So I'll jump over to the engine actually,
we'll go through this kind of node by node basis.
So if we open this up in our anim graph,
we'll see a few things.
The kind of first thing to highlight here
is that a little bit like the material graph
for anyone who's used to using that
or has some experience there,
the anim graph works right to left.
So this right most node is our final output
for the kind of pose of all of our bones
and therefore the way our character actually looks
for that animation frame.
And when you're talking about the logic,
the branching that kind of goes backwards from that node.
So the path that the node follows,
the path that our whole code goes through
to kind of define this final pose,
the branching is kind of followed backwards
from the right towards the left.
So if we kind of take this first node
as our example here,
we have a blend poses by Bool node,
and that will blend between two different paths
depending on this Bool.
So in this case,
this slipping Bool that we did,
I've used a knot here
just because it means that I can be a little bit tidier.
Otherwise the slipping pose would be up here
and it'd be kind of in the way of the rest of the,
in the way of the rest of the predefined anim graph.
So I just thought it would kind of keep it more separate.
But generally the concept here is pretty simple.
If this is true,
we would be following this path.
And if this Bool output's false,
then we followed this path.
So down the false path,
what happens is we go,
we're just reading from our slipping state.
This is a state machine,
which we'll talk a little bit more about later,
but actually this one is incredibly simple.
It's basically just got a single animation inside of it,
which is our slipping pose.
The way we can actually really easily demonstrate that
is worth talking about in itself.
We have, if you open up your details panel,
we have got a couple of things here.
We have the edit defaults,
and this is basically just all the variables
on your anim instance,
pretty self-explanatory,
you define their default state.
But in the edit selected instance,
what you're actually doing
is kind of editing a preview instance
of your animation blueprint.
I mean, you can kind of make changes there
to just see what your anim graph would do,
but you don't actually, you're not,
you know, if you hit play,
none of this information would actually get used.
So for example, here,
we can freely toggle between slipping and not slipping,
and we can see what actually happens to our character.
We can see the anim graph update,
and we're now going down this path,
but also you can see the final pose is being rendered.
So this is a beautiful animation
that I constructed myself,
just in engine to have something
that didn't look like the idle or the walking or whatever.
So if we go down the true path,
this is the section that a typical Manny ABP
would already have in it.
And because we're kind of not really talking
about branching logic anymore,
it kind of makes sense to follow this branch
all the way down to the end.
So where we,
and because the reason for that being actually
worth touching on briefly,
is that where the branching logic is kind of right to left,
when you're thinking about the way
the final pose is constructed,
the ordering of that is kind of left to right.
So our leftmost nodes are then,
the nodes to the right of them are applied over the top.
So that's why it's kind of helpful
to then go all the way to the left,
because everything that's done after that
is kind of additive on top of.
So first off, we have our main state.
This is another state machine.
Again, we'll go into that in more detail just after this,
but you may be wondering why this locomotion pose
seems to be sampling at the same time.
Like when we go into our slipping state,
you can see it's not being used, but here we are.
And that's just because if we quickly jump
inside this state machine
and go inside the locomotion state,
you can see we're using this cached pose locomotion.
So cached poses are essentially,
it's a little bit like writing a function in C++
that you write just to not have to recreate the same code,
the same five, 10, 20 lines of code
in five or six different places.
Pose caching is essentially the same thing.
If you actually try to plug in some logic
into multiple places in the anim graph,
it won't let you do it.
An output pose can only go to one thing.
So that's kind of where pose caching comes in.
It lets us reuse this pose, whatever we create.
In this case, we call it locomotion,
but I could just do cached, new save cache pose.
I could just call it whatever I want.
I can call it Bob,
and then you can use Bob wherever you want,
and you can plug that in.
You can just use that pose multiple times,
and you can plug that into multiple places.
And that's equivalent to plugging locomotion
into all those places,
or whatever logic you have going into that cache pose.
So it's because that our main state
uses that locomotion pose
that we're seeing that cache pose
be kind of like calculated
every time we're running that main state.
So after our main state state machine,
again, we'll go into state machines
a little bit more in a second.
We've got this default slot being applied.
Now, as we talked about a little bit
when we looked at anim montages,
they can play into particular slots.
So let's just quickly jump to our jump montage,
and ignoring the sound effect briefly,
we can see on the left here,
we've got all these things for our notifies
and stuff like that,
and we define a group,
a slot that that anim montage plays into.
So what that lets us do
is inject montages that play into that slot
at different points in our animation blueprint.
So maybe we have an anim montage
that only affects the hands
because it's like a gun reload animation
or something like that.
And in certain situations,
like for example, when I'm slipping,
I don't want to allow montages
that affect the hands to come into consideration,
but down another path, I do.
So that's kind of where our slots come into play
is that this kind of lets us filter in
and out different montages.
Yeah, so this is where our montage would come in
if we're playing any into the default slot.
And then over the top of that,
we have this control rig node.
Control rig is a kind of advanced system
that gives you control over the individual bones
of a skeleton at runtime.
We don't need to go too much into that,
but you can kind of tell from the name here
what this is being used for,
which is some IK tracing.
For anyone who's not familiar with the term IK tracing,
IK stands for inverse kinematics,
it's essentially giving us control
of the end bone of a skeleton
and defining where we want that bone to be
and the skeleton going up the chain
and working out where the other bones need to be
in relation to that,
so you get a kind of more natural pose.
The kind of most common example when this would be used
is when we're placing our feet on the floor,
or say, for example,
we have a character brushing up against a wall,
we don't want that arm clipping through the wall,
so we can place the hand on a surface that we detect.
That's the kind of typical cases for IK tracing,
if IK in general,
but obviously there's a lot of different ways
you can use it.
Maybe it's your boss's head when they do a fire attack,
you need it to follow a particular path,
you might use IK when you don't know
what the pose of the rest of their body is gonna be.
So as you can see,
you can infer from the check that we're doing here,
this slip chance is actually,
that's just an example where I was plugging something in.
We're basically performing this IK trace
when we're not falling.
So is falling is the ball
that comes from our character movement component
is when we're in the air,
so we're not doing our IK tracing
when we're in the air.
Obviously, if we jumped up into the air,
we don't want our feet
to stay magnetically attached to the floor,
we want them just to take on
our whatever jump pose we're doing.
So we are doing the IK tracing when we're on the floor
and we're not doing it when we are in the air.
And so that's how I kind of pose layers up.
We have the state machine,
then we apply any montages
playing into the default slot over the top of that.
And finally, over the top of that,
we're doing our IK,
and that ordering is quite important.
We don't want our IK to be done
before our montage slot, for example,
because if our montage affected our feet in some way,
suddenly our feet will be coming off the floor,
which kind of defeats the point
of doing the IK in the first place.
So that's the actual general structure of this anim graph.
It's relatively small.
If you were to see a full anim graph from a shipped game,
it would likely be a lot more substantial than this.
This is just a kind of a good example.
So talking a little bit more
about the broader concepts of the anim graph,
one of the key things to bear in mind
is there's a reason the anim graph
is distinct from the event graph.
And one of the things that that lets us do
is unlike the event graph,
the anim graph can make use of multi-threading.
That is enabled by default,
but the way you would toggle that
is if you go to your class settings,
if we look up, use multi-threaded animation update.
So as you can see by default, this is on anyway.
And what this just kind of does what it says on the tin,
obviously with an anim graph,
you might be doing a lot of operations
and calculations on bones.
It could get quite expensive
and particularly when you have tens, possibly hundreds
of characters on your screen,
being able to break that up
so that we can make use of multi-core architecture
is obviously gonna be relatively useful.
So that's enabled by default,
but that doesn't necessarily mean
that that multi-threadedness can necessarily be utilized
if we're doing certain things improperly.
So what that means is there's only a certain number
of operations that we can actually perform
on our anim graph safely.
One of those is just getting values.
We can be relatively sure that those values
aren't going to change mid anim graph tick.
So that would be grabbing any of these variables
that we have just defined from our event graph.
We know that our event graph is run first
and then our anim graph runs after that.
So if that's broken up into multiple threads,
we can be relatively certain that those values
aren't gonna change during those anim graph threads firing.
We can also perform any,
well, we can also perform any pure functions
on the anim graph,
but it's worth talking about something here.
So if we have a function here
and we were to mark that function as pure,
it can get used on the anim graph.
But if we untick pure,
so that's just like a normal function
that you would see in your event graph.
If I were to call this sum return function here,
we'd see that's what a normal
on real function looks like.
Again, this is covered in our previous talk,
but if we change that to a pure function,
it would look like this.
So the function is kind of run
as we try to get the output of the function.
It's only pure functions
that can actually be used on our anim graph.
So if we put that here, that works fine.
If we change that from being a pure function,
suddenly it won't let us use it on the graph.
So for a start,
functions have to be pure to be used on the anim graph.
But on top of that,
those functions,
if we want to utilize that multi-threading properly,
we need to make sure that those functions
aren't doing something that wouldn't be thread safe.
So if I actually put that here,
and there's a setting that we can use on our,
in fact, maybe I would default it'll actually do this.
If I plug this in here,
it's gonna basically generate a warning for us
saying that essentially this function isn't safe,
that we're using potentially thread unsafe call.
So the way we would stop that
kind of complaining about this,
it would say,
well, specifically that we're gonna make sure
that this function is thread safe,
which we just do by tagging this flag here
and making that function thread safe.
But what that actually means is that our,
by marking a function as thread safe,
it kind of limits the functions that we can call by that.
When you say a function is thread safe,
that function in turn can only call
other thread safe functions.
So there is,
it's not just a free thing.
You don't just take that flag
and then you get all that functionality for free.
It does have certain implications about
what you can and cannot do in that function.
The other thing to be aware of for optimization sake
is the idea of AnimFastPath.
This used to be a setting in your project settings
that you would have to enable,
but again, it's on by default
and I don't think you can actually even,
I don't think it's actually available
in the project settings anymore,
but you'll notice on the AnimGraph,
we have these lightning bolt icons.
That means that this is utilizing, as it says,
FastPath enabled.
This node is not using any blueprint calls
to update its data.
And that is pretty much encapsulates
exactly what FastPath does.
FastPath is when you are not using
the blueprint virtual machine in any way
to feed into your data.
Because as soon as you're using
the kind of blueprint logic end of things,
it's going to slow things down.
So the point of FastPath is basically
just hooking into native code
and we're not using anything else
that might slow the AnimGraph down.
If I were to plug some value in,
even if it's just a float that we have
on our AnimGraph, you can see
that that's going to be okay with no complaints.
We've still got our lightning bolt.
As soon as I do even some logic to this float,
so just a multiply, even if I multiply it by one,
so it's going to end up as exactly the same value,
we suddenly lose our lightning bolt.
And that's because this is no longer using FastPath
because we're doing some blueprint logic
to feed into this value.
We should be trying to minimize
and have preferably absolutely no blueprint logic
in our AnimGraph.
Anything that is going to feed into that value,
it's better if we do it in the event graph
and then just read that data into our AnimGraph.
As you can already see,
when we're doing things like that,
we are occasionally getting warnings
and that's because I've got this setting here
which won't come turned on by default,
which is warn about blueprint usage.
So if we have that turned on,
then we'll see we get warnings.
I don't think that's turned on by default.
So we can see we get a warning
that we're essentially doing some blueprint logic
to feed into this value.
And that's just a really helpful thing
to kind of remind you.
But if you kind of know what you're doing there
and you're doing that consciously
and you just don't want these annoying warnings around,
you can just turn warn about blueprint usage
off on your class settings
and that's not going to complain in the same way.
The logic is still happening,
but it's just not going to warn you.
So that about covers it for the AnimGraph in general.
Next, let's look at state machines.
So this is an example of our state machine
that is present in this same animated AnimAVP.
This actually doesn't have
any additional logic on top of it.
So if we just go inside here,
we can see this is our land jump fall loop.
And if we go inside our locomotion state machine,
we can see this is a locomotion state machine
that we've demonstrated there.
So I'm just going to talk about, use the images now
just because it's kind of all in one place.
But the way the state machine works,
the state machine is not a concept
that is unique to animation in Unreal.
It's a broad concept.
It's the idea that you have a system
that can be in one state at a time
and these states define
how they might transition to each other.
It can sometimes be used for game screens
and plenty other bits of logic,
but in the context of the AnimGraph,
they have their own bespoke implementation.
And essentially a state can be represented by just,
quite typically it will be represented by just an animation,
but you can actually go inside a state
and have whole other sequences of logic in here.
You can have a whole bunch of nodes feeding in
that define what actually goes into this state.
You can actually have a state machine
that feeds inside the state of another state machine.
So you can go pretty, pretty far down the rabbit hole here
but in this case and in majority of cases,
it wouldn't be surprising if the majority of states
that you see are just represented by an animation.
And so the way that these states transition
from one state to another is defined by these rules.
When you would actually manually specify
that a state can transition to another state.
If I were to add one to our state machine here,
I could just call this state whatever,
I'll just call it Alan.
And by default, this state isn't entered into.
If I wanted to be able to transition into a state
from another one, you would just simply hover
over that state, click and drag and connect that up.
And what this is essentially saying
is that we can transition from this state to this state
when this rule is true.
And that has very particular meanings
that is a one-way transition.
So we can see here that idle can transition to walk run
and walk run can transition back to idle.
That is not the case here to Alan.
Alan cannot transition back to walk run
unless we go to Alan and we manually define that
in which case this is a two-way transition.
So that's already implemented as an example
that is already implemented in our main states.
We can see here, this is made a little bit more confusing
by the fact that we're using state aliases
which I'll touch on in a second.
But if we just park that for a second,
we can see that from our two falling state,
we can transition into jump
but jump can't go back to our two falling,
our for loop can't transition back to jump.
So this flow only goes this way, okay?
If we were to actually jump into one of these transitions
we can kind of look at what that might look like.
It's essentially just a ball that says,
can we make this transition?
And this is getting asked all the time we're in a state.
So whenever we are in any state,
so if we just jump into our idle state, for example,
it is cut every frame it is asking,
is looking at all the states
that the idle state can transition to.
And it's basically querying what this rule is.
So in this example, we have,
it's just asking whether should move is true.
So if that were true,
then we would transition to walk run.
And then at that point,
we would be in the walk run state
and it would be constantly asking,
querying all the transitions that we can make from walk run.
And in this case, it would be back to idle.
And the question it's asking is,
should move not true, okay?
So if we were just kind of given an example of that,
I don't know where should move is,
but if we look it up, yeah.
If we were just to set that to true,
we can see instantly it would transition to walk run.
And if I turn that off again,
then it transitions back
and you can actually see that transition firing, okay?
But each state can actually transition
to multiple different states if you so desire.
It doesn't have to just be a one-to-one relationship.
So if we were to take this example here,
we've used, again, state aliases have been used here
to kind of tidy this up.
But actually what is happening here,
if we kind of like remove these state aliases
just for a second to kind of simplify this,
what we've actually said is,
if I were just to quickly look at those rules,
if we took the same rule and applied it here,
so I'm just gonna quickly delete these,
I could connect land to jump and land to fall loop
using those same rules, right?
So clearly if I'm falling
and our velocity is greater than zero,
then I should be going into fall into our jump state.
And if I just quickly go back
and look at what the transition rule was before.
Okay, so it's just going into our fall loop
if we don't have any upwards velocity.
So if I would just repeat that,
that would be doing exactly the same thing.
So just the same thing, but without that logic there.
So if we are falling and we have upwards velocity,
we would transition to jump.
And if we're falling and we don't have upwards velocity,
then we would transition straight into our fall loop.
What the state aliases allow us to do
is just prevent having so many lines.
If we wanna be able to do those exact same queries
for our locomotion to jump
and our locomotion to fall loop,
you can see we end up with a pretty complicated graph.
And then, you know,
fall loop needs to be able to transition to land
and jump needs to be able to transition to land.
You end up with this like incredibly verbose
and complicated looking anim graph.
What the state aliases let us do
is kind of describe exactly the same thing.
I can just undo back.
But they essentially say, you put in the state alias.
So if I would just add one here and you just say,
which, if I just drag this down here,
you just say, which states is this kind of a shortcut for?
So the two falling is kind of acting,
the rules it's applying are rules that are applied
to both the locomotion and land,
meaning that both locomotion and land
can transition to jump using this rule.
And they can both transition to fall loop using this rule.
And it's just the same in reverse,
to land is applying the rules for both jump and fall loop,
meaning jump can transition to land using this rule
and fall loop can transition to land
using this rule as well.
So the state aliases are just kind of there
to make that a bit visually easier on the eye
and understand how that flow works.
But ultimately the logic being executed
is exactly the same.